I'm gonna tell you a story about a ghost  a werewolf and a pretty shitty pizza  place it all started when the werewolf  came back to town pizza delivery boy was  murdered while making a routine delivery  Kingfisher Chronicle can ask you a few  questions find the wolf you'll find your  killer tonight ghost involvement but  killing abroad hammerschmidt  looks like I'm going on a wolf hunt  tonight  what the [ __ ] does that have to do with  pizza your pizza place is a gateway to  help  wait so you telling me my pizza place is  built on a gateway to hell I've been  saying that what never  calm down another thing you should have  ended a long time ago  [Music]  oh [ __ ] god damn what's wrong with you  you